if you follow eSports then you've
probably noticed that competitions and
tournaments have been getting more and
more media attention from sports
websites some tournaments have even been
broadcasted on live television but it
looks like ESPN is doubling down on this
variety of sports today ESPN announced
and launched an internal division
dedicated to eSports the division is
appropriately called ESPN eSports and is
being pegged as a destination for
comprehensive coverage surrounding the
world of competitive gaming ESPN's
competitive gaming content will be live
on a special hub on espn's website ESPN
coms editor-in-chief chad millman said
you can expect ESPN's effort in the
gaming world to be of the same level of
quality content and journalism that
users of espn.com have come to expect
this will include in-depth looks at the
competitive gaming world and on-site
reporting from the major tournaments one
of ESPN's highest-profile business
riders Darren Rothwell is working on
esports content alongside a founding
staff member that includes former
GameSpot editor rod slasher Breslau
whether or not this means eSports will
get more airtime on ESPN's channels
remains to be seen for more gaming news
stay tuned to gamespot